Đi này, đảng đã xác định đất lúc chính thức mối quan một chuyện với phát triển mới,
khi bên bên mình của xin tọc Việt Nam. Nếu nằm xưa, phải trải quan vui lắm nằm xup đi,
để toàn dân vùng lên dành lại dạng dân. Thế ngon này, chúng ta phải tập dụng từng khoảng khác,
từng ngon lực để lực xáu lên. Bài học lưỡng mặc em mạng khẳng tóm để lại,
chính là có một đường lối lách đạo đúng tắn, phát phy xin mạng toàn dân tộc.
Bài học tâm, sẽ mạng mấy cái cây tích mới.
Khi kích mạng tóm đủ ra và dành tháng lợi. Tời chuyện kế người nông dân, mùi trữ,
trên lắm tay bồn hôm qua của nật lộn để kếm tình những ăn thóc hỏi cái nạn chết đối.
Soar đến những gửa chi thức, tay học, định cao, tời nhiễn thế chiến sĩ vừa trong tụ ra,
cho đến vì không sai đại thành của chỗ nguyện. Đều lứng chung mượt bống cơ.
Bước chỉ xây dực lại, hồi xuyên lại nóng xong.
Tế thì bây giờ, kế kính mệt vinh mệt vinh vũ chúng ta cùng phản như vậy.
Nóng ta không thể đẹp ai tục lại phi xong, mà ai cũng phải đứng chung vở đợi gố,
để sếp chặt lượng ngữ và cùng không tạo nên cái con thẩm lịch.
Thì chúng ta mới có thể phát triển đợi.
Thì cùng chung mượt ý chiến mượt khác vòng, chúng ta đã xem định đột lắm.
Và cũng vũ tình thăm ấy rất tọt Việt Nam, rất định sẽ vừa lên mạnh mẽ.
Vậy tiếp những chung xử vang cho ký vừa phát triển mượt.